عقود طويله للتعافي من عواقب وتداعيات
انهيار سد كخوفكا الذي وصفتها كياف باكبر
واسوا كارثه باي من صنع الانسان في اوروبا
منذ عقود لان الخزان اي خزان كخوف كان قلب
احد اكبر انظمه الري في اوروبا ومياه هذا
الخزان ساهمت بزراعه ما يصل الى 80% من
المحاصيل الذراعيه الزراعيه في اوكرانيا
وتجدر الاشاره هنا الى ان السد يعد احد
اكبر السدود من حيث السعه في العالم بنحو
18 كيلومترا مكعبا من المياه اذا مشاهدينا
المشهد الكارثي هذا سيخفي معالم الحياه
لدى العديد من القرى بهذه المنطقه
والبلدات على طول نهر النيبرو وايضا اي
ستصبح هذه المناطق غير صالحه للسكن مع
اختفاء الحيوانات والنباتات وفق الجاردين
البريطانيه الخطر ايضا يكمن بالحطام الذي
تحمله المياه المتدفقه وهنالك الحشرات
الالاف من الالغام تدفقت مع مياه الفيضان
عبر خط المواجهه في الحرب هذه مما سيؤدي
طبعا الى تغيير النظم البيئيه في المنطقه
الى الابد لان المياه ستصبح ملوثه بعدما
اختلطت بمواد كيميائيه مثل التسرب النفطي
ومياه الصرف الصحي وغيرها طبعا وهذا الامر
سيؤدي مشاهدينا الى انتشار الاوبئه
والفيروسات والامراض بهذه المناطق ويعيد
تشكيل خريطه اوكرانيا
وموانئها وسبل عيشها وتحديدا بعدما وصلت
المياه من الخزان الى برك التبريد لاكبر
محطه للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا اتحدث هنا
عن محطه زابوريشيا على الرغم طبعا من ان
الخبراء النوويين قالوا حتى الساعه بانه
لا يوجد تهديد فوري هذه طبعا وفقا
للتحذيرات الغربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات